we're back with david dobrik
isn't this cool the la studio it's
insane
it's insane can i like am i allowed to
like break this illusion
look at this yeah i know right
wait what how did you come over to my
side oh hi i'm in l.a now
oh gosh it's so warm and delightful oh
wow
this is insane it makes literally this
literally makes no sense
hold on can you try to meet in the
middle because i'm not kidding it
i'm wondering if like hold on
how are you coming to my side because i
can't go to your side how is that
happening
i know why can't you come to my side
you're like divergent like you can enter
both worlds and like i can't
i'm stuck here yeah how come i can't
walk everywhere that's bizarre well
anyway it's not fun i'm glad
i'm glad you like it because you're
techy and cool so if you think it's cool
then that's okay great all right so we
are gonna
surprise your friend and we've got him
on zoom
jason he thinks he's on a radio show and
he has no idea that i'm here
he doesn't agree that 51st dates is a
great movie
david loves the movie thank you so much
i'm honored i'm sure adam is too
so we're gonna trick him and i'm gonna
come in at some point all right take it
away david
jason david how are you good
i'm doing a pop quiz and uh we need to
see what answers we have in common so
i'm just gonna go rattle off a bunch of
things okay
okay got it okay um your favorite
musical artist
three two one lana del rey
did what who stu
again i i don't understand why we can
never agree on a single thing okay
favorite your favorite color three two
one
yellow blue okay favorite
favorite movie uh this one's tough okay
okay
okay three two one fifty first dates
see that's this is this is something
we'll never meet in the middle about
jason despises that i think 50 first
dates is in the top 10 movies of all
time
it's just a it's just like a it's just
like a lighthearted
kind of comedy and i don't think it
deserves to be called one of the
10 greatest movies of all time that's
all yeah but you don't but you don't you
don't get it like you don't understand
that that's kind of what movies are
supposed to be as the light-hearted
yucks are like the most important part
i'm just saying i just think we need to
say like the top 10 best of all time
all the time you you think adam sandler
drew barrymore being in hawaii
doesn't make the movie that good that's
your problem
i'm i i i it's like i'm talking to a
brick wall
jay if you could put 50 first dates in a
top something what
what what top movie would you put it in
top what what's your ranking
top 10 david idiot movies i would put
that in there
oh really top 10 idiot movies
oh my god interesting
yeah jason now what what are you going
to do now
jay what do you have to say for yourself
go ahead tell drew tell drew how much
you hate 50 first dates
if drew barrymore wants to put her name
in uh her opinion in film right now and
stated on the show
that 50 first dates is one of the top 10
movies
if she wants to say that it's one of the
top 10 movies of all time
i have 500 reporters waiting by
to quote you and to say
and i love that i love drew barrymore i
love adam sandler
i i my kids we just watched the one uh
when you go to africa
i just lived it this weekend um i
you know it's so hard because i could
never say
that anything i ever was in would be in
a top ten
of anything because then i would be a
self-indulgent you-know-what
don't say don't take it i don't like the
movie i think the movie's great
david is saying it's one of the top 10
movies of
all time well it looks like the beef is
squashed
i wonder yeah and i can't believe you
did this to me david
well here's the good thing this is
election week and this is the week to
say that everybody's favorite things and
least favorite things and
likes and dislikes and everything in
between
gets to gets to be okay and we should
enjoy
each other's differences and celebrate
them
jason thank you for letting me invade
uh your world hi drew barrymore
david thank you for being on this show
i love talking to you today thank you so
much we'll be right back
thank you
[Music]
you